The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So now we
have this last exercise.
I'm creating a mysum.
I'm going to go through
all of these values
and you guys have already
told me what values these are,
5, 7, 9, not 11.
And I'm going to add to mysum.
So I'm going to keep a running
sum adding all of these values
together.
So the very first time
through the loop, mysum
gets the value of 5.
That's this line here.
The next thing I see inside
this loop is an if statement.
If mysum is equal to 5.
That's true.
So I'm going to go
inside this if statement.
The next thing I see is a break.
If I see this break
am I evaluating--
am I evaluating
this line or not?
No, exactly.
Because whenever Python sees
break, it's going to say,
I'm going to stop right
here, exit out of the loop
that I'm currently in, and
go to the statement that's
immediately right after it.
So what this is going
to print is mysum.
And that's the exercise
we were looking at.
Let's see how the class did.
Pretty good.
Hopefully if you
answered one of these,
the explanation
was-- was all right.
If not, just go back and try to
work through it step by step.